hello
this is my final project for precision
medicine program
applications of translitomics and
machine learning to post more than
interval estimation
a preliminary study let me introduce
myself
i am an assistant teaching professor and
graduate program director of the
professional science masters
in forensic science at florida
international university
in florida in miami florida i am a
forensic scientist with a background in
biomedical science
my projects apply transcriptomics
proteomics
and epigenetics to forensic science
issues
like it's just that estimation or
determination of post-mortem intervals
like this project
apart from the precision medicine
program
i completed two other programs omis
omics logic data and transcriptomics
in biotech
and now let me introduce the project
there are several
methodologies to estimate the
post-mortem interval pmi
or times instead based on changes that
occurs
undergoes after that however these
methods
are imprecise due to the composition
process
being affected by several factors
current trends
attempt to estimate the pmi in a
quantifiable manner
based on chemical biological and
microbial changes
leading to the fields of thanato
chemistry sanatobiology and
pharmacomicrobial
so based on trans-systemic data from
mysticism
the aim of this study is correlating
gene expression changes with pmi
leading to estimate in a quantifiable
manner times instead
for this i used transmitomics data from
a previous publication from mice neural
retina and retinal pigment epithelium
retrieving from 0 to 24 hours after that
data were analyzed through the bio
platform
applying unsupervised and differential
expression analysis
additionally correlation coefficients
and uni and multi-regression analysis
were performed in significant genes
first neural retina and rpe
have differential guinea expression and
using exploratory data analysis rpe
in rpe pca show a clear separation
between
the early pma groups and the late pmi
groups
also clustering applying clustering k
means
indicated this separation in retina pca
and k means results were variable
however
both these display differential
expression of ends through the pmi
some of them with strong significant
correlations
based on this data gene expression could
be quantifiable correlated with the
pmi although this giving correlation
depends on the tissue and signaling
pathways activated
and as conclusions this study provides a
quantitative method to estimate the
post-mortem interval based on
transatomic state future research may be
able to expand the results
applying in human thesis and extending
time since the
estimates and
let me introduce a little bit the whole
postmortem interval
problem so postmortem interval is
defined
postmortem interval pmi or times instead
is defined as the the time
from when the person died
to the time when the course is
discovered or
the course is sending to the lab there
are classical methods
to determine the post-mortem interval
and these are based on changes that
occurs undergoes a third day
also forensic entomology is based on
insect activity the colonization of
different species
however this method cannot
quantify will determine the postmortem
interval
and also are affected by different
environmental factors
for the reason new methodologies are
trying to estimate the pmi
in a quantifiable manner taking into
account
these influencing factors like
temperature
and humidity the first developed method
is called thanato chemistry and is based
on chemical changes
for example the analysis of volatile
fatty acids recent trends are based on
molecular biology thanatobiology and
microbial colonization
thanato microbial for this project
i focus on my
pharmacobiology methods thanato biology
methods
have been recently developed and these
new
trends have been analyzed at different
levels dna degradation
rna degradation differential expression
and protein degradation expression
these methodologies could improve the
pmi estimates as
next generation sequencing technologies
allow to analyze
several samples and genes at the same
time quantifying
expression levels this could lead to
better and accurate
pmi extmes so based on
transcriptomics data from mice neural
retina and retinal pigment epithelium
the end of this project is to study the
differential expression of genes through
the pmi
to find a correlation between this
expression and the times instead
as material and methods i use process
transcriptomics data
from a previous publication this one
with this
geoaccession number briefly
the authors use c57bl60a
mice sacrified a 30 days of age
and they start neural retina from now on
retina and retinal pigment epithelium
rpe
from now on at different times
after the 0 15 minutes 30 minutes 45
minutes
1 hour 3 hours 6 hours 12 hours and 24
hours
and four miles per pmi
this data was analyzed using first
exploratory data analysis
using principal component analysis but
first i performed
quantile normalization and then the pca
and also the data was clustered using k
means and finally the differential
expression of the genes
was analyzed using the dissect
2 algorithm this 2 is a method for
differential
analysis of count data that uses a
shrinkage
estimation for dispersions and for
changes to improve
stability and interpretability of
estimates
this enables a more quantitative
analysis
focus on the strengths rather than the
mere presence of differential expression
and this is really useful for
lower expression express genes
for in that way we can take into account
these genes
in the whole differential expression
analysis
after the differential expression
analysis i prefer
correlations and for
data follow a normal distribution i use
person correlation no normal data
i use raw experiment and
finally i performed uni
a multivariate regression analysis to
create formulas to determine the pmi
in terms of results first i
decided to analyze if retina and rpe
have differential expression on the
of the years so as you could see on the
picture of ei
retina and rpa are closed so
it was good to know if they can they
have different expression
and in this case treated them as
different thesis
of if they have the same expression the
same type of expression
and for the reason i use the time 0 to
analyze this and i applied the dissect
to
algorithm the deception algorithm gave
me two
two plots m a plot which represents
the law for change log of the ratio of
level counts for each team between the
two samples against the log
average the average of level counts for
each c
across the two samples and the volcano
plot
the volcano plot is a scatter plot of
the negative logarithm transformed
p-values
from the specific test against low
fall chains and as you can see volcano
plot
gave me also the differentially
expressed
genes as you can see from the red dots
here
and the green dots here effectively
retina and rpe different
expression gene expression for the
reason we have to treat
them as they are to independent thesis
and the first thing i did was
to analyze data using exploratory
analysis
using principal component analysis or
pca
and as you can see here although first i
applied quantile normalization
as you can see here in retina
there is not clear separate group
separation
however the two components explain 82
percent
of the variance in contrast in rpe
we can see a separation between
later pmis 12 to 24 hours this one
and early pmis zero to six hours and the
two pca components
explain 74 percent of the variance
so based on this exploratory data and
the pca results
i decided to see if the samples
or the pmis can be clustered
and i use k means
and i got the same results as with the
pca
as you can see in retina there is no
clear separation of clusters
however in rpe i got the same results
as in pca later pmi samples
12 to 24 hours cluster together
early pmi samples from zero to one hour
cluster together and there was more
variability
on intermediate pmis three to six hours
i think in retina the problem was the
variability itself
of the of the sample so for the reason i
couldn't see this
separation
and now my next step was to
analyze the differential expression of
the genes and i
started with retina and i'm going to
show you first
the m a plot and here you can see
the analysis respect to a previous time
point
i did also the analysis of its time
point
respect to zero like this one so for
example 0 versus 30
minutes 0 versus 45 minutes
and i got the same results as the
previous publication
here i show you the analysis to
previous time point to show you the
tendency of the data
and as you can see again the red dots
represent
the significant differential express yes
from 0 to 15 minutes we can see there is
a differential express
gains not so much from 15 to 60
minutes however later pmis
and particularly the last hours of that
show the highest differential expression
we i got the same result using volcano
plot
and i show you this because i use
volcano plot
for the next step the correlation
analysis and volcano plot
points or mark marks the
differential express genes again
in green you can see the differential
expressions
and i also did from zero to different
time points but
here i use only i show
only the respect to the previous time
point
and as you can see here
from 0 to 15 minutes there is a
differential expressions
not so much in this case from 15 to 45
minutes
and then when i increase the
pmis you can see the highest
differential expression
occurs in the last hours
based on this volcano plot
i select these skins to
do a correlation analysis in bolt
you have the significant correlation
analysis
significant correlation means that with
the time
there is an increase or decrease in the
gene expression so for example positive
correlation
means that there is an increase in the
in expression negative correlation there
is a decrease
in the gene expression and also
the strongest correlation is one
the one the value of one and here for
example
you have an example of a strong
correlation
and based on this correlation
i here i graph
the genes that were selected for the
posterior regression
analysis and i got the
strong the strongest significant
univariate regression
using the c61 gene
and remember it's a positive also
correlation
with an r of 0.9
13. and in multivariate regression
i got the strongest one with 361
rick and lf2 and rick and llf
are negative correlated so here you have
the
function of the genes 361 is involved in
inflammation
and tissue preparation which makes sense
with the
death event also rick and elf
are involved in transcription regulation
so 3x61 is upregulated with the
pmi in contrast rig and lf2
are downregulated or maybe
their rnas are degrading so
i'm not sure about this it could be
downregulation
or uh the degradation of the rnas what
is clear is that
here 61 is up regulated
now i'm going to switch to rpe and
the same this one i plot respect to
uh the previous time point but i did
respect
zero respect to any time point and i got
the same results
as previo the previous publication and
here the tendency is similar as in
retina
in the first so from 0 to 15 minutes you
can see
a differentially expressions not so much
from 15 to 60 minutes
but this increase in the later pmis
and here is earlier at six hours
six versus 12 hours we can see a high
differential express gins
and also the highest is from 12 to 24
hours the same results using volcano
plot
here you can see more differential
expressions
from 0 to 15 minutes
also in the previous from 15 to 16
minutes
and then again the highest differential
expression
is in the last hours and again
based on volcano plot i
choose these gains for the correlations
you can see here
involve again the significant
correlations and here you can see the
majority
of the genes were downregulated or
maybe the rna is degraded and
here i plot the ones
that were selected in the regression
models
the strongest significant univariate
regression
was with atl3 with an
r of 0.854
and for the strongest significant
multivariate regression was with atl 3
and peak
5 atl and pot 1b
and with rs of 0.985
and 0.938 atl 3 is involved in actional
maintenance
peak 5 is involved in membrane
homeostasis and both
1b involving telomere protection so
remember
from here both 1b
was the only one with positive
correlation
means that product1b was
upregulated with the pmi
so if it's involved in telomere
protection
makes sense that because of the death
event
try to protect is activated to protect
the telomeres
the other two atl3 and pk5
are downright regulated or maybe the
rnas were degraded
and also this set to pipeline
gave me different effective pathways it
would be interesting to
analyze these differentially expressed
genes
in its pathway and try to create
regression models to determine the pmr
so as conclusions this study
demonstrated a differential gene
expression through the pmi
in mice retina and rte this differential
gene expression depends on the tissue
and this differential genius expression
was higher in later pmis
12 to 24 hours some of the
differentially expressed genes
show a strong significant correlation
with the pmi
the revolution formulas were created to
estimate the pmi
based on significant correlated genes in
order to accurately determine the pmi
it is required to take into account all
differentially significant
expressions and as a result a more
complex statistical
models future studies will be able to
expand the results
applying a human thesis understanding
the pmi estimates
thank you very much